foreign
good afternoon
I'm Jim parody
one of the members of the steering
committee but I have to say uh
congratulations and thanks and my
admiration for Professor Manning who has
put this material together and created a
great conference for us all and we're
all sitting here learning from each
other
and so
thanks Ken
[Applause]
we're at the end of the conference and
my dear friend and and close friend uh
William uricchio is going to be talking
about uh on the subject of the forensic
citizen
uh and the subtitle of his talk is
learning from the past and preparing for
the future
I'm looking forward to this event
because William is someone who thinks
about these areas in Media
continually and very creatively
he's one of the founders of the CMS
program at MIT
he's also the founder of mit's open
documentary lab
and he's co-authored a new volume with
Kat Zizek that's titled Collective
wisdom co-creating media for equity and
justice
so it's a tremendous subject that is
spot on for this conference
and this publication will be launched in
a couple of weeks in Amsterdam and New
York
um
William is a historian of media who
revisits the histories of old media when
they were new
explores interactive and participatory
documentary
he writes about the past and future of
television
thinks about algorithms and archives and
researches narrative in immersive and
interacting interactive settings
he's a professor of comparative media
studies at MIT
he's also been a professor at many other
institutions around the world certainly
in Europe and the U.S including Utrecht
where he holds another position
um he's been a visiting professor at the
Free University in Berlin at Stockholm
University
and China University of Science and
Technology
he's won many awards he's
done fellowships Guggenheim fellowships
and
his the recipient of the Berlin prize
and his Publications include reframing
culture
we Europeans media representations
identities
another
media cultures
yet another many more lives of Batman
and the soon to appear Collective wisdom
volume
so William has been
present in the media
research area for many many years
what's interesting is media is really
one of the
tremendous subjects of our time and
we're beginning to see it feeding
a kind of world back to us
that for many people is surprising
but it's been there for a long time so I
I want to
welcome William and uh
ready to listen to his his presentation
on the forensic citizen thank you
[Applause]
thank you for those kind words Jim
um and I have to say it's been an
amazing two days uh this is kind of the
as Jim said as you know at the end of
the arc I will be much shorter than
promised this will not be an hour and 15
minutes don't worry about that
um
but I have to say I've been moved by
what I've heard I mean emotionally
touched by some of it inspired by some
of it um
Blown Away by by some of what I've seen
it's been a remarkable two days and I'm
really indeed honored to be here and
because this is only going to get more
extended with each last person Ken Ken
Manning um
Ken Manning is is an amazing figure and
I'm sure you've all gotten to see him
around he's the one person who's not
been at this Podium for the course of
the conference but he's been behind
everything that happens Ken is a
magician of
making things happen while kind of
sitting back and watching it play out
and I'm I've learned a lot I've learned
a lot from Ken
precisely with this kind of thing among
other things he's a wise man and I'm so
grateful that he had the the wisdom to
pull this off the fortitude to pull it
off it was not an easy uh task as you
can tell if you've been to any of our
our normal conferences this is being
done at a much higher level and I'm I
it's a testament to Ken's uh ability and
also this isn't this is a topic that we
need to address as as fulsomely as
possible
I'm also impressed by the array of the
of the speakers I don't know that I've
been recently at a conference at MIT
with all with five continents
represented I mean there are folks from
Asia Australia Europe South America
North America it's um it's amazing it's
a it's not the usual siled kind of
disciplinary conference that I'd spend
my days going to uh this or this you
know as you guys know from having met
one another people from quite different
areas from quite different positions in
the academic hierarchy and from outside
it so just to say it's been terrific and
um the Keynotes have been
yeah
yeah and the Keynotes have been awesome
I'm intimidated I don't usually get
scared before I speak but like after Sam
and and Alyssa I mean this is this has
been a great uh a great series of
Keynotes okay
one last thanks and that's to Samantha
Fletcher and Tracy Jones both of whom
have teamed up Samantha has done
yeoman's work in making this uh the the
details the these are incredibly complex
processes as I think any of you have
done this no and Samantha's really
pulled out and Tracy has been just a
pillar of support behind it also thank
you guys
bearing witness Seeking Justice the
conference papers as I said have been
really inspiring offered an array of
entry points
um into the power of individuals to
witness to Bear witness to create video
testimonies
bearing witnessed as we've seen in many
cases boils down to the courage of a
lone individual someone willing to stand
in a tense situation pull out the camera
and do something
um
but Seeking Justice has a different
dynamic
bearing witness tends to be an
individual Act
it's an act where our integrity as a
person our
it's the safety of our bodies is on the
line
but justices justice as we usually talk
about it is more systemic Justice is a
social process it's a there are
institutions behind it
we haven't talked a lot I mean obviously
some papers have but we haven't talked a
lot about how to go from bearing witness
to making that act of courage mean
something find traction make a
difference
um
so many historical cases demonstrate
bearing Witness by itself can be ignored
suppressed marginalized
sometimes it gets buy-in sometimes it
gets momentum those are the cases we
know but for every case we know I'm
willing to bet that there are hundreds
that are not seen
it's an interesting study what makes a
case stick what makes something
be sticky or go viral
I don't think we necessarily have as
much agency as we think in this
there are these are complex
configurations of power that
sometimes wind up Injustice and in many
cases wind up just with with nothing
um
Barry witness you know we've we've
talked a lot about the power of the
phone and and videography and the
numbers are encouraging I mean uh
in the United States average cell phone
age is almost three years but they still
have cameras and they're still pretty
good and they're probably high def and
penetration rate here is
pretty good something like 95 percent
in the rest of the world it's not
forgotten but it's it's it's certainly
there
um
and I think an assumption one of the
assumptions for a lot of what we've
spoken about again not all is that there
is a truth process here a truth telling
process I use goddard's reference here
but you know as as the work that uh Sam
Gregory has been doing it witness and
that we've been helping with someone
with deep fakes uh these are the truth
is not assured in the image uh it feels
good to think that but I I'll ask uh not
so true anyway my aim in this talk is to
step back and put this amazing work of
seeking uh of of bearing witness into
the larger context of Seeking Justice
um
and just try to look at what's in that
landscape that both confuses the story
or might help to accelerate its uh
presence spoiler alert context can be a
depressing thing because there's a lot
of noise out there all of the tools
we're looking at cut both ways at least
both ways sometimes like they cut three
or four different ways they can be the
the technological enablements for civil
good the cell phone can be repurposed
with malice or Worse simply mundane
technocratic control and oppression
which we're seeing more and more of
these same Tools Plus the same social
formations can be put to highly
Divergent ends as we know with
disinformation campaigns uh Q Anon the
work happening in Q Anon is
the the forensic impulse is writ large
but what the what the folks come up with
is is kind of frightening so this is a
complex terrain and I just want to call
that out to some extent
so
if we think about the technology side we
we we've celebrated rightly celebrated
the use of cell phones for bearing
witness but we know that the state has
an incredible apparatus at its disposal
armed with AI facial recognition you
name it and that this is growing much
more pervasive this is growing by the
minute
um
these are two very different paradigms
in terms of how we witness the state as
witness its own witness and and we as a
you know surveillance and surveillance
which we've heard a lot about
um
so
they're obviously radically opposed in
other sense one is our agency and and
something we have control of something
the other is is being done to us that
space as I said is growing quite quickly
um
there's a kind of potentially
commonality here and that is in the
panoptic effect in the sense that
someone is always watching when you look
at the cell phone penetration rates I
just mentioned 95 in the U.S the
likelihood that whatever a police
officer or or anyone else does there's
someone nearby with the with the camera
is highly likely so that in a certain
sense mitigates the kind of uh more
structural presence of surveillance
cameras
um
so it's all is not lost
um
so yeah we talked about this the split
between witness and Justice
um the other side of it is how do we
make sense of these bits if we want to
use goddards these these bits of Truth
or these these bits of evidence what do
we do with them and and Sam pointed out
the importance of uh narrative for
example like we need to do something
with it in a way that that that
incorporates it that encodes it that
that makes it part of an argument that
makes it palatable makes sense
um and it's what you're seeing at the
top frame and we'll come back to this
later is an image from the guardian a
two-year series they did called uh the
counted which they basically
crowd-sourced evidence of uh of deaths
uh at the hands of police that's in the
United States at the hands of police the
FBI uh you might you may remember a
couple years ago there was after George
Floyd in fact the the question came up
how many people die in encounters with
police in America each year and that
seemed to be a question that was
unanswerable even the Federal Bureau of
Investigation did not have an answer to
that question and so the guardian
launched this project where people
across the country could just send in
reports of this happening and then the
guardian would vet it they would use
their journalistic apparatus to to make
sure this was uh
you know yeah indeed properly vetted
so a really interesting example of a
journalistic organization doing
something that they could never do just
with their report with their reporters I
mean one or two reporters would get the
the job of counting deaths in America so
impossible task for the newspaper unless
they work with the public so this is a
great example to me of a kind of of a
collaborative methodology
um that that is is still responsible
invented on the other side we have
something like the the Q Anon stories or
the
um
the 5G you know the rotting your brain
the lizard people you name it these
conspiracies that have that have taken
root in in our internet culture that
have uh that have fostered and and grown
there
um where people's forensic impulse is is
Unleashed in ways that are really not
productive uh it's a it's a dog chasing
its tail and it's doing so with great
Vigor
um
so both of these strike me as as tapping
in a way the the forensic drive that
that that we seem to have that forensic
itch that that
seems to pervade the race but in
radically different ways one really
productive and one really unproductive
they represent two very different
epistemologies one kind of reality based
and one one I'm not sure what to
describe it as
okay
so I want to just start with
surveillance and I guess the point I
want to make in the next couple of
slides is simply that not not just that
surveillance is an old story but that
each New Media form that's entered our
our ecosystem our culture has almost
immediately been put to use for purposes
of surveillance and and it's always been
a double-edged practice
here you're looking at some uses of
Photography back in the back in the 19th
century and uh
who gives who gives us fingerprints
um his project was actually quite
interesting and he also he was also into
ear prints and nose prints and not
Prince but like images of noses of lips
of foreheads of physiognomy where he was
convinced that he could find traits now
we think of fingerprints as a unique
identifier and he thought of for example
the ear as a unique identifier but not
so much in the sense of like oh we have
an ear print because you don't get those
so often but rather in the sense of a
predictor of a certain proclivity a
criminal proclivity a low BR think of
think of villains on
cheap television shows or in comic books
low brow you know certain kind of nose
or jaw that kind of that kind of set of
assumptions was was kind of built into
what he did
but it's also part and Par this this
kind of comes back with some of our
facial recognition Technologies and it
comes back in our emotion trackers with
the work of uh uh duchenne de bologna
who did a lot of experiments the
interesting images of sort of shocking
mental patients faces and with with the
conceit that what what uh when the
twitch occurred when the when the
Grimace would occur that these were ER
States these were like basic states of
the of of the sets of the face and in
this particular example he Compares he
Compares it to classical
um sculpture to show that these are
really kind of conditions of the pure
states of of human affect
readable legible from the outside
and again if you think today of where
our Technologies are in terms of emotion
trackers things that are judging whether
you're happy or sad or potentially
dangerous
there is a direct line back to some of
this work so although this happened you
know although this seems ridiculous at
some level it is very much present in
some of the thinking around our current
Technologies
um
the camera especially the coming so the
camera is developed in maybe 1830s but
film stock that is instantaneous has
introduced more mid-century 1850s 1860s
and by around 1900
cheap easy to process instantaneous film
was widespread and there were there was
a there was a plague to use the periods
language a plague of kodakers people
that used Kodak uh running amok through
New York streets and other streets I'm
sure taking uh surreptitious photos of
other people
surveillance the police of course also
used it for surveillance so that double
edge photography is already embedded in
practices and pretty widespread a pretty
voluminous amount of Pros in newspapers
or complaining about this practice and
you're seeing some sort of candid a
candid a cane a camera cane and some of
the kind of shots that might come from
it
um
this around 1900 already so this
doubleness is already in place and this
notion of surveilling seeing the world
unseen filmmakers like veritab will make
a big deal about seeing the Unseen and
cap capturing reality unawares uh
celebrating that and rightly so but it
does have a difficult history
um
television has a pre-cinematic history
going back to maybe the 1870s 1880s and
not as a object not as a working
technological uh fact but rather as an
anticipated set of desires and these are
this is from Alberto robida
um
in this case 1890 and one of the
Striking things in robida is in his
fulsome description of this technology
called the telephonoscope he he really
outlines a series of of vignettes of
scenarios where how this thing is going
to be used and it's going to be used for
news and it's going to be used for
entertainment and it's and he has a
whole bunch on how it's going to be used
for voyeurism and surveillance in this
case voyeurism
so again this is hard wired into the
imagination of a technology before it
even gets off the ground this uh this
sense
thank you
uh
the dystopian side of it of course is
robustly represented in in future films
um the surveillance side of it with with
chaplain in this case
and um
yeah okay so gear shift
um
so it feels like I jumped a slot but
maybe I didn't so anyway this is to jump
into a section on this sort of forensic
this this impulse that we have and I'm
not sure if any of you are followers not
followers but like read on observe
observers of uh Q Anon but uh it's a
really fascinating space a deeply
fascinating space people invest hundreds
of hours in terms of the kind of
forensic work that went into tracking I
mean there's like thousands of pictures
of Hillary Clinton's open mouth trying
to prove that she is a lizard and um
there are some 13 million people
um
allegedly not even allegedly I mean this
is uh New York Times is my source maybe
I should have to say alleged there that
uh that that our Believers in the kind
of lizard uh takeover so
a little bit worrying
um but it is exactly the same impulse
that we use when we're trying to analyze
like what happened with this with this
death what happened with this Riot and
let's look at the footage and figure it
out it's that same impulse just directed
in a
ridiculous way
and frightening all the more because of
its endorsement from the highest levels
of of uh of authoritarian political
party in our country
yeah I am somehow I screwed on my slides
oh this was just a reminder that this
this observation this surveillance and
surveillance valence uh I'm kind of it's
kind of value free at some level there
is great stuff a lot of our cultural
history our cultural memory comes from
this it's not a necessarily evil thing
or a great thing but it's it's a thing
nevertheless but
um
and this is just a reminder to say that
the Technologies we're talking about
here in in the case of the camera are
not race neutral technologies have
biases and the and the biases in
photography are really striking and you
know striking in the sense we can talk
about black and white photography and
color photography the problem in color
photography is finally sorted somewhere
in the 1970s I think it's Kodak gold
that that is brought to the market it's
it's reasonable with black skin black
skin looks
the tones are brown or are black or are
visible they're not green or just
uninvisible but Kodak markets that in
the 70s as being you know this is a film
stock a color film stock that's great
for dark woods chocolate and and brown
horses
and it's like what
you know of course you know what this is
about and
not said not spoken in the ads up until
that point and you can see that by by
the um Shirley girl up there this was a
Kodak color color stock reference the
Shirley girl is always white and almost
always described as normal so this kind
of okay so you say okay it's the 50s
that's the 60s maybe even the 70s like
forgive them their sins but when
Instagram comes into the world
it's not different if you look at the
beautifying filters in Instagram their
bias is to lighten up
um
if you look at uh Joey bulimwini's uh
work here at MIT and now
I should know where she is now and I
don't but with the algorithmic Justice
League it's remarkable work that shows
the inherent the built-in bias in these
facial recognition systems in the in the
AI systems that we're using here so all
to say you know we could talk about the
camera and what it does but in fact we
also have to think critically about
these Technologies particularly when it
comes to to racial issues
the
the shackling of image of images to
image recognition systems to facial
recognition systems is a really
frightening step uh one that
in China has gotten quite good because
now you can do it with masks and it
still works I mean that's that's not a
lot of data to be to be um
making identity uh claims on
I'm not sure what happened to these
glasses this is an image from around
2013 and they kind of stopped appearing
online so I'm not sure it either went
like
covert or doesn't really work but these
are these are little facial recognition
glasses so that the police on the street
can know who's who and what's what
that's it seems unlikely and I'm not
maybe this was just a big PR Blitz they
did at that time but there is really
interesting information coming out of
the times that's looking at the supply
chain and trying to figure out trying to
assess what's the state of the game in
terms of this kind of sewer surveillance
um and in our own country it's starting
to get a little frightening this with
the you know a moderately I don't want
to say progressive but a moderately
a a left of center mayor and uh this
linkage of what's on your ring phone
ring ring camera and what's in your shop
linking that in real time with police
cameras is you know it's it's civil
liberties Union and others are really
quite concerned about this and rightly
so so just to say I'm not China bashing
uh we're just we're trying to catch up
we're doing our best
um
just one other side to this that's kind
of curious later in the presentation
we'll we'll see an image from a a
Belgian artist to be used to Porter who
takes Instagram photos and connects them
to the live EarthCam footage of that
person posing for the footage so that
maybe you saw this in the times but that
that really super looking photo and then
you see someone working for like two
hours to just get the right photo
um so he did this he posted it you know
he's an artist he did
does great stuff and he he put it online
and it got pulled from YouTube because
EarthCam claims
they have they have surveillance cameras
all over the place and they claim
copyright they claim so when you walk by
you are part of the copyrighted world of
EarthCam so there's there's the issue of
of governmental surveillance and
governmental the potentials for
oppression but there's also kind of a
marketing part of this that's a little
frightening that your data is now part
of a data set like it or not why in
documentary you've always got to get
people to sign releases here
no they just don't it and uh
so
it's a reminder that you know Jeremy
bentham's panopticon that Michelle
Foucault wrote so much about and uh this
idea that a few guards in the center
turret can control the whole prison by
observation that notion is the one you
see embedded in the in the little glass
Bubbles and on the ceilings of stores
but it's it's really become pervasive in
our culture as I said earlier because
all of us have the cameras and um
okay
the forensic urge so what is this urge
where does it come from what are its
cultural specificities
I have Barnum up here and Neil Harris's
book humbug
Neil Harris has a wonderful thesis on
this idea of humbug so humbug is just
like
nonsense that's the
fakeness in a way
and he has a book on the role the place
of humbug in 19th century early 20th
century America it basically makes the
argument that this is
an incredibly important cultural
characteristic of the United States and
he goes through anecdote after anecdote
Barnum is his primary case where people
love the debate the more absurd the
claim the more passionate the debate
it's never about are you right or
ultimately right proven right or wrong
that's inconsequential and I think some
Trump understood this instinctively it's
the debate say something outrageous and
let the debate follow
and people there's there's a kind of it
happens in quotes in air quotes people
aren't really you know invested in these
positions but they act as if and it's a
it's a very curious phenomenon it's
something quite I mean I live a lot in
Europe and here it's something I don't
you know it's traces in Europe but here
it is indeed and Trump is a
manifestation of it a a really
um
a really profound thing and I
I want to bring that up because it's an
interesting frame to think about the
forensic urge in its americanism
there is a way here you know Q Anon is
like that's they're CopyCats in Europe
but this is the place where it's a
passion uh the lizard people I'm sure
you could probably find a few Believers
in Europe but here 13 million and I
think it comes it's all with that kind
of tongue-in-cheek almost true what if
um the kind of speculative engagement
with the world but one that it's made
affordance is that you can dive deep do
your forensic things scratch that
scratch that forensic itch find evidence
Here There and Everywhere and put it
together and that's what's so striking
about the discourse online that it's the
evidentiary approach to it it's that
people are finding things comparing them
um
so all to say that the wisdom of the
crowd
is not necessarily a great thing I mean
I've just written a book that Jim
mentioned Collective wisdom and it's
very much about trying to co-create and
work with people
but there's there can't be a toxicity
and we know that we know that from the
witch trials and we know it from the the
Kennedy the the Kennedy assassination
theorists and we know it from the 9 11
folks you know this is a CIA plot or
whatever what is that
and how can we channel that how can we
take that impulse and drive it in a way
that's productive as opposed to just
kind of going off the deep end
um I use a uh you know
again I refer to the Deep fake work
people are indeed spending a lot of
money trying to like refine that
technology and there's a lot of clunky
stuff out there but at some level it
almost doesn't matter it almost doesn't
matter and I think the Earl Morris's
statement of it in this in the title of
his book believing is seeing that
believing pre believing determines what
you see and which goes way back to the
pre-socratics
um
this is a pretty powerful notion that we
don't see the World We Believe something
and then we find it in the world
there is there are there are people for
whom that is emphatically the case and
um
so it it for me it's it kind of
decenters the whole issue of deep fake
which is which is a of course could be
used to bolster an argument but for a
lot of people it just doesn't matter no
matter how fake no matter how absurd how
how crude the fake
that's not the issue it's already you
they've already been sold on it
um and this is a really good example to
me uh Barbie's book um
is it looks at the for example there's a
Pruder film as you know I'm a film
historian from from house out
this is probably probably the the three
minutes of the most analyzed more people
have analyzed this footage and seen more
different things in it than just about
anything the closer you look the more
strange things you find it's like how
does that work and she document she
documents this and it really is a great
example of different belief systems
coming to bear on a piece of evidence
and in fact the evidence ultimately
supporting all of it or
not supporting any of it
but it it's about a kind of
epistemological break and that break
which was kind of there already when you
know in the 60s uh that Heather talked
about uh kind of being a little more
pronounced at the end of the 60s is in
full uh
full flame right now
um
social media have obviously given if we
think back when Kennedy was around I
mean we're talking a bit like in the in
the late 60s with Heather's talk a a
world with very limited Outlets with
more more just you know filtering is an
issue
choice is an issue three main
broadcasters but what's fundamentally an
issue is temporality yes there's live TV
but precious little
yes there's live TV but easy to
circumvent as Heather showed us
um with these media forms
temporality is everything
as is the spread so is the spread the
breaking down of filters but also the
fact that instantaneity is possible
is really one of the one of the things
that's really changed the condition
so that the kind of
accumulated inherited wisdom we have in
media studies it's kind of coming from
photography through film to television
breaks at this point because the I think
the temporal the the shift in temporal
conditions is is simply profound
um so
yeah
and if you if you haven't seen this book
and you're up for like a good page
Turner read it's it's it's it's a fun
book and it's a scary book it's written
I want to say in 2014 and I I only read
it like last week but
I can't imagine being surprised by the
Ukrainian situation
if I'd read this book earlier and it's
it's it's by a a documentary producer uh
russian-born British bred
goes back to Russia after the after the
fall after the end of the Soviet Union
is a hot shot because he's perceived as
English and basically kind of walks us
through a number of investigative
stories and the ecosystem and the
structuring the the hard wiring of
disinformation in that world which is
very much part of our world here and
more and more of a social media really
really facilitates this to some extent
um it's it's quite useful it's quite a
useful
um read but anyway just to say given
that epistemological uncertainty that I
referred to earlier given that that
forensic drive this on top of it just
kind of leads to a trifecta of confusion
uh
yeah a trifecta of confusion there it is
okay
um okay so gloom and doom sorry let's
switch to like how can what the hell can
we do how can we I'm going to be very
pragmatic here Sam gave us a lot of like
forward-looking you know like let's
think about getting in there at the
standards level as new technologies are
emerging and making sure this won't come
back to bite us I'm going to be like
really next couple of years next five
years and look but I think there's some
great examples I will tell you right at
the outset Again Sam I'm going to abuse
your name up here there is a there is a
issue of equity here there is a this is
something the first world can do in a
way that a lot of other parts of the
world can't
um
and we have to find ways to fix that and
we have to find ways to even make what
I'm showing you now more more vigorous
but let's get going
um
you know how to go from witnessing to
Justice that's the that's the key
question
I just want to start with this this
point back to the 1930s this wonderful
project a couple of uh
former Cambridge University students got
together and started this this amazing
project to document everyday life in
Britain and they got I don't know a
couple hundred people involved to keep
Diaries and
what's interesting about this project is
that it was a bottom-up project there
was not government funding this was like
hey cool idea let's look around world is
changing fast let's figure it out led to
a number of policy changes ranging from
the kinds of posters that the the the
the British were using to you know in
the warm-up to World War II
to the to tax uh policy uh which started
to change as a result of better
understanding better insights into the
lives of the ordinary people so this was
a really inspiring project it kind of
comes and goes it still exists in a way
but just to say that this kind of
surveillance meets surveillance can
happen if there's structure if there's a
framework
one historical precedent the Arts are
another great police this is the these
deporter piece that I mentioned where
you see the Instagram shot and the
posing
the
I was wondering what that was I've seen
these people on the streets kind of
dancing around and now I think I better
understand it
the Arts a great way to interrogate this
space and I'm not going to go into the
Arts I'm going to go into really
pragmatic ways to use this footage to
take this testimony and to do something
with it
so it's going to really boil down to a
couple of things like ngos and and Sam
Sam's talk was a real inspiration in
that regard witness does great work and
it's 30 years of great work and it's
it's great work in terms of like on the
on the ground like documentation as well
as thinking ahead and figuring out
what's coming down uh down the pike
um
it's something that the folks in
Amsterdam and uh with bellingcat do in a
really wonderful way I was surprised to
find the National Post Lottery it's one
of their funding sources God bless the
Dutch
um they do remarkable investigative
stories again using you know using open
source material using open source
intelligence
really working with any material they
can find in highly creative ways to sort
of document what seems to be
undocumentable for uh sometimes the
mainstream press and certainly for some
governments so ngos are a true some ngos
are proving to be a place of real
important activity in terms of being an
interface between stuff that's on the
streets and things that turn into
reports or finally get into the courts
or you know finally make it to the Press
um
yeah open source intelligence is okay
press is another really terrific Place
alas these examples in the Press are
rare so the Guardian newspaper I love
but these kinds of collaborative
examples this is a little bit more
information on the counted are are a
last few and far between but here what
they basically did for a two-year period
was was sort of document
um these deaths and you could get a you
could get a little if you click on one
of these images you'll get this little
blow up with the story the documentation
um there was a an interface where you
can slice it and dice it by the age of
the victim whether they had a weapon or
not how they died it was a surprising
number of people die by tasers like
something like 20 25 was really quite
surprised by that uh by state by Race by
by whatever so this is a very
interesting tool but it's also kind of a
narrative it's a narrative that you can
you can construct your own narrative by
working with this data
and a really a really Noble initiative
and a sign that this kind of
collaboration between us and Them
between us we in the streets and the
folks that work in the newspapers
it can happen it's a great example of it
alas as I said there aren't a lot
uh the Times Obviously and you know
other newspapers have been doing good
work lately again using videos using
citizen produced video and then and then
analyzing really really working with
that and working with in this case it's
a lot of found material from the
internet some of the analysis working
with that and then bringing it to a
bigger public uh
uh so there's some this is a thing
they've I think the times is doing a bit
more regularly
um but it seems to me this is a space we
really need to think more about how can
we come up with more robust forms of
collaborative journalism working with
the kind of credentialed respectable
responsible press but in a way that
takes that makes use that does things
the Press can't do alone and and does it
in a way that verifies the work we're
doing on the ground takes testimony
turns it into Justice
even as we speak there's a our Dean
Melissa our former Dean and now and now
um Chancellor Melissa nobles with uh her
her good buddy Margaret Burnham Margaret
has a new book out this is a long-term
project over at Northeastern where year
after year law students were sent went
to the I think over the Christmas breaks
or whatever they went South
and they would try to find Cold cases
cases from the 20s the 30s 40s
year after year and a database started
to accrete of mostly black men who died
in mysterious ways uh disappeared there
was one streetcar that I remember here
that one streetcar line that I don't
know like seven or eight men never made
it got on and never made it off and
you only start to see these patterns
when you can go through huge data sets
so by throwing this Army of lost you
know
lawyers in training loose on these data
sets uh they were able Aid to find a lot
of them I mean patterns that are pretty
shocking B to learn methodologically
that you never try to work with the
local courts or the local police like
that leads to
parking tickets arrests uh
you know no information but if you try
you know and that she's outlined she and
her students have outlined the ways that
do work so all to say it's it's turned
into this book they also have a database
behind it that's what's on the other
side and it's being presented right now
the book launch but this is a really
really important project and again a
sign of what okay we've talked about
ngos we've talked about the press in
this case what universities can do
universities can do powerful things
because a they're training the future
but B that process of training can also
be a data aggregator and a data analyzer
a way to turn witness into Justice this
is uh Goldsmith's forensic architecture
is it amazing if you don't know these
people you should they do incredible
work uh really incredible work and
transformative work and it always shocks
me that this is a lab at a university
um so again they're working with all
kinds of data sets creatively
they're working they're definitely going
against the wind against the against the
waves they're going against a lot of
vested interest to come up with the
stories uh they do they're reporting on
Israel has has really been quite good
among many other stories so just to say
this is uh if you if you don't know them
keep an eye out for them but it's a
university that
and finally I'll point to the the
project we did where this you know it's
just about to come out it'll be out
start in November but the the idea of
co-creation is to try to build trust and
to try to to try to
harness the power of people by working
with them not trying to do things for
them they're not doing things about them
but working with them and in so doing
trying to build relationships trying to
build trust uh trying to establish
credibility and so we've been this is
based on a lot of field work on tons of
interviews but you know we have sites
field work sites like in Kentucky we
have a couple of different sites in
rural Kentucky where we're trying to
work with unemployed coal miners or
folks in the in the rural Outback to
figure out how these communities can can
you know what are their needs and why
did their newspapers disappear what what
are their news sources what do they want
how can how can how can we imagine
together ways how can we leverage our
brand and our the stuff that we as MIT
can can help in a situation with what
they want and how can we make that
happen together so there have been a
bunch of different
um Endeavors here to to try again to
Leverage The Power of individuals
from witnessing to doing something
bigger systemically on the level of
trying to achieve Justice
um
so yeah the the there's a tension I
think that just to summarize you know
between the kind of applications of the
technology on the one hand and the kind
of investigative drive and also
narrative frames that we're giving to it
and and to me these are the key
questions you know how do we how do we
um
how do we imbue our media practices with
ethics ethics it's a it's a funny ethics
is a philosophy Department started to
fade in our universities ethics were
kind of the first thing to go they get
trotted out as as ornaments as Google
has shown us so so
sadly
um
but I think we have to think of media
practice and ethics in the same in the
same breath
um it is it's inherent and maybe it's
like even stupid to say it here when
you're talking about witnessing ethics
are kind of part of the job
um
but anyway that's that's you know and
how do we how do we direct this energy
in a way that's productive and not just
such
psychotic means broken from the world it
means deluded and and again we inhabit
this moment of a kind of epistemological
rupture
it really doesn't matter what you say
sometimes because it just won't be heard
and we have to find a way to suture that
so that's why I'm focusing on these kind
of mainstream organizations again
admittedly this is all kind of it's very
tangible concrete
but everyone everyone you know I'm sure
witness can use more money and and More
Boots on the ground and I for sure the
newspapers can use a lot more creative
thinking in terms of working with
communities not just talking about
communities or selling newspapers to
communities and universities need to do
a much better job of not just you know
getting out of the Tower and trying to
interface with the world uh partner with
our communities and make a difference
so that's I think it thank you
for sure
we have time for a couple of questions
if anybody
if you've got any energy left after all
this uh
two days of two intense days
hi thank you very much for the talk
um so
we are talking about these
collaborations between like press
University
other institutions ngos and the
communities
this is at the time that in the U.S and
in some parts of Europe
the trust in almost all of these
institutions that all-time low right and
we see that
a lot of times people get to those
spaces like Q Anon when they see one Lie
by political institutions and then
that's like leads them for example to a
YouTube video that they see it and then
they just go down that rabbit hole of
algorithm
suggesting them that's like oh you're
interested in these lies let me show you
more and then they suddenly become even
like flatter it's so easy to go down
that rabbit hole so and then like in
Academia we have the problem of class
right that there are reports that
increasingly The Faculty of humanities
are coming from upper middle class upper
class and their interests and their
concerns don't necessarily align with
working class lower middle class
so I'm wondering that there's a lot of
work that and then the of course the
issue of press that is owned by
corporations the vast majority of them
so what can
all of the how can we even
re-imagine first the institutions from
universities to press and all these
political institutions and the
algorithms on platforms so that we gain
that trust again so that we can work
together
yeah thank you thank you for that
um
so I think it's about what I've shown
here are hints uh because the guardian
doesn't do this very often they've done
it as far as I know once you know for a
two-year period sustained and important
they've done some other interesting
projects but but basically they don't do
a lot there are not outlets for people
to sort of put their forensic
imagination their forensic impulse to
work there aren't there aren't Outlets
the right actually provides a fair
amount of like you get a lot of feedback
from your peers and you and off you go
what are we what are the sort of normal
people the normies doing you know we
don't really have those opportunities so
much so when I look at just a couple of
these couple of examples like I think
they need to be much more visible there
have there need to be Outlets
built rebuilding Community is Central to
all of this I think it's um that's
Fallen away a little bit and I'm not
going to point at social media but it's
one of one of the factors in there
exacerbated by things like covet
whatever most recently but in the making
for a while so so I think you know like
a very different I mean you know Pie in
the Sky very different notion of how we
arrange our politics so that the local
matters a lot more and it's not just
this kind of
crazy National media game when in fact
the realities are all local Republicans
seem to understand this so for example a
lot of the focus on school boards in
this country has been a really I think
quite interesting and effective tactic
to sort of to Galvanize people's energy
to Galvanize their desire to have some
kind of community interaction and dig in
and Fight For a Cause
okay in a reprehensible way but what's
the other side doing and it's nothing so
I think part of the problem is avoid uh
in terms of a place for people to
put to work what they're worried about
what their concerns are that's not a
good answer and and it's a con and
obviously step out of this cultural
frame and it gets complicated in all
kinds of other ways
um
yeah not a great answer but
sure
so going off of of the last question and
I'm thinking about what institutes like
MIT can do to partner with schools we
were just in there with the high school
students to have them thinking about
collaboration
um in a way that it feeds into this
pipeline when we're thinking about
ethics like you said that's not
something that's being learned in the
classroom now but how do we bridge that
Gap and what are your thoughts on that
yeah so so thank you and I think there
are incredible opportunities
for example neighborhood no one knows
neighborhoods better than the folks who
live there and
we live in a media era there's a lot of
new tech out there that that people want
to learn about how can we you know one
way is to sort of have have localized
work with high schools to have training
about let's just pick something
arbitrarily um augmented reality okay
hip cool whatever
if I think of Somerville where
um I live here every intersection has a
name on it like the the the sergeant
McKinley square like who the hell is
Sergeant McKinley and there's a there's
a probably someone and maybe someone
interesting or not but that's a story
that's a researchable story but more
even more interesting is how did
Sergeant McKinley's name get to be there
whose name isn't there what's the
pattern of names those are those are
very easy to research things and very
easy to geolocate data so you're
teaching kids the technology you're
teaching them the research skills to to
kind of figure out how this happened in
City Hall who decided this name and not
that name what was that process and
you're giving them kind of look at how
the power works and like what do we need
to do to fix it really hyper local
really but but you know fun I mean I I
haven't worked with young kids that much
but I get the sense
like the kind of stuff I talk about in
the classroom is probably not going to
be interesting but this Hands-On stuff
might be a little more so that kind of I
think take advantage of the place where
you are and so much of I mean not so
much but there are there are really a
number of elements of what happens at
MIT that are completely relevant for
the neighborhoods and where we can where
we can learn from the community
um
MIT is better than a lot of Institutions
I would say
um at least the ones I've worked at but
if there's a lot more we can do and um
other questions uh certainly conferences
like this
make a difference yeah because
conferences like this don't just bring
academics together they bring a lot of
different people from different walks of
life including different ages so if we
have a
direction to pursue it's to strengthen
the offerings of these kinds of uh of
organ of
groups meeting like this and you know
talking about some of these issues and
publicizing them
other questions
thank you for your talk amazing as
always I have a question about
Okay so what do you think about using
surveillance right ignite people but
then
how surveillance like you know like how
the community then start to feel like
paranoid and you know like creating
I guess like I will tell you in the case
of the delivery workers right in the
case of the Liberty workers they work
that I'm using yeah so they are uh you
know like reporting uh uh when they see
someone that potentially could be a
thief right but then and that started
because they had a problem right and
they started building community
but this I'm starting to see that it's
becoming a problem because now they are
seeing you know a Target in different
people and they are like targeting
people that might not be you know like
thiefs so I'm just wondering like
yeah it is important so it's Valiant and
also like in igniting you know like the
community but then it has like a
backwards right or like a like another
problem that I'm starting to see with
this community and I I was just
wondering if you have any like have you
thought about it or yeah
yeah so I guess I thought about it in
the sense that these are always
double-edged at least double-edged uh
Technologies and and applications
and I think I kind of want to pardon me
the hopeful part of me wants to say
we're in this transition period we know
that we have we know that the
surveillance the state you know the kind
of number of cameras are rapidly
increasing that that side is there we
know that
for me the surveillance side is an
interesting counter force a
counterbalance
um and I Wonder Part of Me wonders like
so what was the public before any of
this
I see you you see me I see everyone
around me everyone around me sees me
like there was we we had kind of equal
access to one another
the game is a little upsided now
especially with facial recognition
Technologies and all that stuff that
we're never really going to get the same
way the state gets but I wonder if we're
not just at a kind of hopefully we're in
a kind of transition that when we when
we all are armed with these things we
all have the ability to watch each other
like maybe we'll it'll either we'll get
accustomed to it and get over it or kind
of figure out that like we're as
vulnerable as we are offensive so let's
just be cool again not a great answer I
I'm just hopeful that it's a transition
a cultural transition moment but um
but you know it's inherent it's inherent
and it's been inherent in these
Technologies from the get-go and as I
showed with photography around 1900 that
double-edgedness is there and
Sam yeah
uh William this this has been an
incredible conference in terms of the
range of discussion it's been I wish I'd
brought all of witnesses 45 colleagues
here that a lot of them have been live
streaming in so just I really appreciate
it I want to ask a question that is
around the link between the kind of
forensic impulse and media literacy
because I think the two get and I'm
thinking about Dana Boyd talking about
media literacy as this Rabbit Hole where
you kind of clamber down of trying to
unpick everything and you end up
unpicking it to the extent that it you
you can't make sense of it so I'm and
often in the work of witness we hear
people talking about you know doing the
type of stuff that a Belling cat does or
a reverse image search as part of media
literacy
um and it's sort of like plugging in
these Technologies plugging in this
forensic impulse into an idea of how
citizens should use their literacies and
it so I I guess the question is really
just like what is the relationship you
see between more broad-based consumer
media literacies and this forensic term
and how do we manage that without it
becoming this kind of impulse to
deconstruct the media until it means
nothing yeah
great question and it echoes uh it goes
briefly back to Jim's opening comment
about just how how important the media
are in our lives and how little we
attend critically to them
institutionally so at a place like this
we a lot goes into like making the chips
and figuring out the latest the liquid
lens and you name it but not a lot into
the kind of critical assessment I mean I
think our program is is probably it and
it's not a big program and it's not a
well-funded program and it seems to be
fun it's fundamental and it's certainly
fundamental on on on you so I'm a huge
advocate of media literacy and I think I
think it's a really
potentially useful way to kind of to
kind of
put it into context the the kind of uses
and abuses of the the of of uh of the
forensic impulse in this regard
because you can make this you can call
this stuff out to be as ridiculous as it
is if you really just take two steps
back if you're self-taught and if you
this is your entree into the world of of
media literacy your friends have showed
you how to do the blow up and you've
figured out how to freeze the frame and
like that's that's learning and it's
progress and I understand the attraction
of that and and you're going down the
algorithmic uh the algorithmic the whole
that the algorithm has done for you
that's incredibly precarious so yes some
way of standardizing and teaching like
the bringing bringing media literacy to
much higher levels is is fundamental and
um
and I I just it's absence from the
curricula
whether whether basic school high school
University it's its absence is in this
era with the speed of trans
transformation of our media forms just
strikes me as a response not only
irresponsible but like willful like it
is it is willfully absent
when we've pressed up we pressed on it
hard here for the maybe first 10 years
of this program
um so let's say from 2000 to 2010 really
worked hard to get it in the schools
MacArthur Foundation a lot of money to
back it like Millions to to do it and
the basic the resistance was so mundane
it was kind of shocking well there
aren't enough hours in the day with the
curriculum or State's testing standards
like preclude any new curricular
material was that kind of very mundane
blockage
um
but it persists and it's stunning and
it's precarious we look at the you look
at the political situation in this
nation and not just this nation it's
it's endangering our futures to be
ignorant about this or to be self-taught
in a kind of half-assed way
um that that has certain affordances and
certain brings certain satisfactions but
also is really dangerous so yeah thanks
thanks for bringing that up
thank you thanks very much this what a
brilliant conference I think one more
word is going to be said but but thank
you all it's really uh yeah
foreign
[Applause]
let me just introduce Eric Clopper um
Eric Clopper professor in the
comparative media studies in writing
head of our department and maybe even
head of I think head of literature as
well this guy wears has two heads so be
careful
I I will be brief um thank you William
um that was wonderful um I'll be brief
as I know uh I like all of you um drank
from the fire hose as we say here at MIT
for the last couple days I mean I think
this was both a sort of intellectual um
fire hose but it was also an emotional
fire hose as well and so I feel I feel
that I feel that in my head
[Music]
um
uh and through that through that process
I've I've learned something I've learned
a lot of things actually and I've
changed um in the last couple days and
as I I think about bearing witness my
definitions of that have changed uh
somewhat I think about it as a more
active process a more Dynamic Global
process and one even more under threat
than I thought before
um but I I reflected actually on the on
the title of the event and particularly
at proposed to the to the last question
here
um you know the the the subtitle of the
event is videography in the hands of the
people but I also think about this and
learned about this as video in the hands
of the people
um it's about what happens to that video
also when it gets out into the world and
becomes viewed by people
um and while the videographer is
Paramount to this to this uh to this
effort um so are all the viewers um who
do something with that with that video
when it gets in their hands I mean I
think that responsibility is increasing
um for the viewers
um as
um authoritarianism racism other forms
of social injustice
um remain orbit or increase in their
pervasiveness and Technology law
provides
um an Avenue to bearing witness it also
provides additional challenges to
bearing Witness
I mean so I think about the kinds of
responsibilities that we as an
institution here at MIT have for helping
with that
um and it's about it's about education
it's about having events like this it's
about it's about the collaboration that
that also was just previously talked
about as well
um and so I certainly think about more
doing a as a department as an
institution about doing more events like
this about making more of an impact in
this area and extending the mission of
our of our unit as well
so with that um I will I'll have a
number of thanks to give here
um I'd like to thank Philip Alexander um
our Provost Cindy Barnhart Mauricio
Cordero I'm Richard Duffy Fox Harrell
Robin Palazzo uh ardene Augustine Rio
who you heard at the beginning and
Andrew Whittaker
I do want to also call out the the
entire conference committee here many of
whom are still in the room with us uh
right now Michelle DeGraff
um John defava Renee Greene uh Tracy
Jones Nicole Harris Heather Hendershot
Caesar McDowell uh Ken Manning
chaconesta muvunga Jim parody Justin
Reich Andrew Turco William murcio and
salafa zudani and I'd like to especially
call out um Tracy is she still here
somewhere she's right there Tracy Jones
um Samantha Fletcher who's also here in
the back Samantha Fletcher who really
swore sort of some of the muscle Behind
these events
and and I will add my special thanks to
Ken Manning
um as as William
as as William as William mentioned
um you would think that in a in a place
like MIT
um that this kind of event would be easy
to put on it's a necessary event it's
the right place for an event like this
and yet it is not an easy effort to get
an event like this produced and and
funded and and underway
um and Ken was tireless in making this
happen
um and he really deserves a tremendous
amount of credit for that and I see I
see
um a satisfaction in his eye as as he
was as he was at the conference and it's
not in himself and his in his
accomplishments because that's not who
he is it was about the accomplishments
and the success of everybody who came on
these stages and spoke and spoke the
truth and made a difference
um and for that for bringing all those
people together I give Ken a great deal
of gratitude so thank you
[Applause]